let's go next to our caller from the
three I like that most people in the
state are caller from three one seven
caller from the three one seven area
code who's this hi David it's me
that is you hi David this is Patrick
calling from Indiana
so recently I was listening to a
conversation between Sam cedar and
Benjamin Dixon and the substance of the
conversation was what Sam described as
the dumb dumb left-right and more
specifically he was talking about Jimmy
Dore and kind of Jimmy's I would call it
progressive purity test and he had
recently criticized Acacio cortez and
bernie for not towing a progressive line
enough and just kind of on a broader
scale he kind of criticizes Democrats
and liberals more than he would ever
criticize a Republican
kind of using what about ISM and whatnot
and I think he basically just taps into
the anger that some people feel on the
left and I kind of agree with Sam and
Benjamin's point about that might turn
off those people from even participating
in the election kind of furthering
progressive ideals yeah so I just kind
of wondered what your take up like on
that whole situation was that if you
agreed I completely agree with Sam and
Ben on this issue I believe that the
involvement of Jimmy Dore in politics
has become completely toxic it I've made
I've cast a wider net in terms of that
toxic element of the left and I don't
know that this is the right
characterization but you might remember
me previously talking about what I
describe as the Leninist left of
Vladimir Lenin Lenin issed
and I don't think it's really fair to
group Jimmy Dore under that but there is
this contingent of the left that by
virtue of a combination of as you point
out what about ISM so-called progressive
purity tests and a whole bunch of other
mechanisms that I've described they end
up being useful idiots and that I want
to be clear calling them idiots is not
it's not an ad hominem useful idiot is a
specific sort of political term that has
basically it means you are unknowingly
be
coming a tool furthering the objectives
of those who you either don't realize
you're furthering the objectives up or
those you would on paper believe you're
on opposite sides I think that it's
become completely toxic I know that
there are people in our audience who are
fans of all combinations of these shows
but I think it is absolutely brutally
completely counterproductive to
everything that progressives are
actually working for I believe it is not
pragmatic I believe it is ideologically
misguided and that that's where I am so
on that issue I'm with Sam and Ben 100%
and if I have a little bit more time I
was wondering if you maybe felt the same
way about saying I like Glenn Greenwald
who's a pretty big Russia skeptic yeah
all that and I don't know any listener
I'm gonna be honest I only am
tangentially aware of what any of these
people are actually doing day to day so
my opinion is based on you know sitting
down and saying let me look at a
sampling of the last three months of
what they've done and they may be doing
things every day that don't fall under
this I've seen less of Greenwald stuff
than I've seen of Jimmy doors like I've
actually seen more of Jimmy doors clips
and and more so than his clips I've seen
a lot of analyses of his clips where
pieces of his clips are played and so
with Greenwald I would be less able to
say for sure but from what I saw in one
democracy now appearance that he did he
seemed to be totally whitewashing any
possible Russian interference or
anything of it anything involving Russia
in a way that seemed extraordinarily and
generously exculpatory of Trump and his
cronies in a way that seems very
disconnected from from the evidence on
the ground all right beautiful that's uh
kind of what I wanted to ask you so
thanks for taking my call big Sam okay
great thank you for calling in really
appreciate it